good morning believe nation today's
messages keep pushing yourself over to
you Todd McFarlane it's just a wide open
void that is a big playground but
because there's really nothing there
that we're competing against and and
some of the things we're trying to
create that there's nobody there kind of
like making us competitive except for
ourselves so one of the things that I
know that we talk about all the time is
we have to keep pushing ourselves we
have to keep reinventing ourselves
because there's really at this point
nothing to compare respond to in America
this is an amazing thought of the day
because if you are leading your field
then it's easy to get complacent and
it's easy to to stop pushing yourselves
easy to get lazy and your own standards
should be higher than anybody else's
standards for you and it's great to have
a goal this is actually super common
ground Chipper you have a goal right
like I want to beat this post I want to
get ahead of that person I want to get
this much revenue I want to be better
than this company and then when you hit
that goal it's it salacious yeah I did
it great and that that whole journey up
in the climb and the excitement but then
when you hit it it's kind of sad because
you need a new goal now because you're
kind of depressed if you don't know
where else we're going to take it and
I've experienced this in my business so
I look at my youtube channel i look at
the agency that I Matt and I have this
somebody else at the agency design I
want to get above on youtube and and I'm
I'm close it's probably going to happen
it may happen before this video comes
out but it's going to happen in the next
couple days to share and now that I know
that I'm gonna pass him it's easy to get
a little down the guy i got i hit my
goal so now what am I going to do I got
to find something else to get excited
about and honestly if I look at the
people in the entrepreneur space the
people who might be I won't i won't call
them competitors because i think they
add content is just a different voice
but I look at those people and I'm
growing faster than all of them like I'm
going to catch all of them none of them
are real competitors for what I'm doing
my youtube channel is growing like crazy
and at the same time that my youtube
channel
growing out of control that I'm going to
catch up and pass everybody I'm pushing
the envelope to move into a three video
a day schedule instead of two I'm
pushing myself harder to provide more
value for you guys to create more
content to be a bigger resource and
inspiration for you give me more
motivation strategies to help you grow
your business and so you need to have an
element of that you need to I think have
a big goal that helps you push beyond
but then once you become the industry
leader you can't let off the gas you got
to keep pushing yourself to do the best
that you can do and so my question is if
you guys is I want to know I want to
know an example of a goal that you guys
had that once you hit it you felt a
little bit of a letdown like you felt a
little bit sad a little bit depressing
or sure what to do next if you can share
an example I love to see that in the
comments below thank you guys so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and i'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events vessel